[Music]
this star
is about to transform into a black hole
and we're about to travel inside it
to see what's on the other side
the only problem is that we'll never be
able to report our findings
back to earth because once you go
inside a black hole there's no coming
back
so maybe there's a better way to find
out what's on the other side
could we use a special telescope
how would light behave inside a black
hole
and why could the first image of a black
hole
provide all the answers
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we could see through a black hole
everything that we can see in the world
around us is based
on light entering our eyes if an object
doesn't emit
or reflect light then our eyes can't see
it
so how are we supposed to see through to
the other side of a black hole
it's like the darkest thing we've ever
discovered
not only does it not emit its own light
it also sucks up any light that comes
near it
but according to planetary scientists
joshua colwell
seeing through a black hole is not
impossible
in fact we've already done it and all it
took
was a little bending of space and time
let's take a look at the first real
image of a black hole
even in this low quality picture you can
see through to the other side
if you look close enough let's enhance
if you want to see what's going on on
the other side of a black hole
the most crucial place to look is at
this thin
ring at its center this is called the
photon orbit
it's a ring made up of light particles
called photons that have
orbited the black hole two three or even
more times
before escaping photons can come
closer to the black hole than ordinary
matter because
they're massless and the crazy thing is
that the photons we see in this ring
don't
just come from the sides of the black
hole they also come from
behind it this is because the black hole
can warp
space and time to such a degree that
some of the light
orbits the black hole in a full circle
let me explain imagine a star
in space that from our perspective is
obscured by a black hole
the star sends out light in all
directions
some of this light would usually reach
our eyes on earth and
some would just disappear in other
directions
but in this case the light that's headed
straight for
us would get sucked in by the black hole
and
disappear forever and some of the light
that
normally wouldn't have reached us will
get redirected by the black hole
this light would become part of the
photon orbit and
eventually make its way to our eyes on
earth
the light appears to come from the
gaseous rim around the black hole but
it's coming from behind it
now yeah i know this isn't exactly what
you were hoping for when you
imagine seeing through a black hole you
want to know what it looks like
inside right
[Music]
well to do that we would need to travel
past the event horizon
which is essentially the edge of a black
hole
it's the point from which nothing can
escape not
matter or light so yeah we won't be able
to report our findings back to earth but
maybe we just want to see it for
ourselves anyway
after we pass the event horizon we'll
arrive at something called
a singularity it can be described as a
point in space where
mass has infinite density
everything that goes into a black hole
will end up here
including all the light it's sucked up
because
you'll be inside the black hole with the
light you will be able to see it but
its direction will be all mixed up you
would probably
just see a uniform glow if you looked
away from the singularity
and darkness if you look towards it and
in true what if fashion yeah that would
be the last thing you'd ever see
so if you don't want to make that
sacrifice but you still want to learn
more about the inside of a black hole
then check out this week's what if
discussed podcast
we'll be talking to professor clifford
johnson about
transparent black holes and new age
telescopes that will allow us to see
further into space than ever before
you